it's time to tackle the global
semiconductor shortage
or as joe biden put it we need to build
the infrastructure of
today and not repair the one of
yesterday
the u.s president has been meeting with
industry leaders to discuss the global
chip shortage that's
hurting manufacturers and especially car
makers
general motors ford volkswagen and many
others
have had to hold production at plants
around the world because of a bottleneck
in chip supplies following lockdowns
last year
one industry group warned that almost
1.3 million
fewer cars would be built this year as a
result of the semiconductor shortage
president biden is urging congress to
back
plans to invest 50 billion dollars in
chip manufacturing and research
as part of his broader efforts to
rebuild u.s industry
ships like the one i have here these
chips these wafers
are batteries broadband it's all
infrastructure
this is infrastructure
we led the world in the middle of the
20th century
we led the world toward the end of the
century we're going to
lead the world again we're going to lead
it again
in the 21st century
for more i'm joined by rajiv biswas
executive director and asia pacific
chief at
ihs market so rajiv will the u.s lead
the world
in the 21st century at least when it
comes to the production of semiconductor
chips
what we've seen is that the u.s share of
global semiconductors production has
declined
since 1990 from 37 percent
to around 12 today and
what we've seen is the rising dominance
of south korea
and taiwan in semiconductors
manufacturing
particularly in the very high-end
advanced
chips and so this is now creating supply
chain disruptions
uh this year throughout of 2021
so far we've seen ship shortages supply
chain
disruptions that are hitting many
industries that are very heavily reliant
on semiconductors particularly the auto
sector
so the us is now recognizing this supply
chain vulnerability
and taking strategic action to increase
its
share of the global semiconductors
industry but of course this will take
time
i think it is very much achievable
particularly with such large investment
under president biden's infrastructure
plan
but it will take some years so at the
moment
the world is facing a semiconductor
shortage in 2021.
now you say it takes time but you also
say it's doable
is it in the interest of the global
economy for the west to really catch up
with asian suppliers so far it's been
sort of nicely balanced asia was
supplying semiconductors
and the west was using it
well i think what we've seen is this uh
increasing dominance of south korea and
taiwan
and in the asia pacific landscape both
are amongst the most significant
geopolitical
hot spots in terms of potential
future disruption even though that
probability may be low
so i think given this steady decline
that we've seen
in the u.s share of semiconductors
manufacturing
and that's been brought to light this
year with these big shortages
that are affecting global manufacturing
and of course structurally the world is
becoming more and more dependent
on semiconductors as
electronics becomes important in many
different industries
so i think that is driving this
strategic recognition in the us
that they need to become less dependent
on
an international supply chain and
particularly in areas such as defense
technology
and other areas of advanced technology
to have
more domestic production capacity and by
the way of course the eu with its
digital compass strategy
is on exactly the same strategic path
with the eu having said that they want
to increase semi-conductors production
in the eu
from 10 of world production now to about
20 of world production by 2030.
so these two economic giants in the west
are both on the same track that they
need to
ramp up semiconductors production
within their own region uh rajiv biswas
thank you so much executive director and
asia pacific chief at
ihs market joining us in singapore thank
you
thank you